okay hello everybody welcome to our q a
with sid our director of robotics
artificial intelligence here at amazon
so hi sid how are you
hello nia it's uh good to see you it's
uh i haven't seen you in almost 10
minutes so it's uh
great to chat again
really looking forward to this
conversation and so uh how about we just
jump right in
sure
okay
so question for you sid
how did you decide you wanted to become
a roboticist
and what do you think you like most
about robotics like what skills do you
have that you feel like have helped you
most in
robotics i i with respect to the skills
i'm still like thinking about that
myself every day is a discovery
um you know one of the things
i've been a professor for
15 years or something like that now
one of the things that i see in uh
resumes or statements from undergrads
and grad students is
they they often start with
you know when i was six years old i knew
i wanted to be a roboticist and here i
am applying for grad school
and uh i
100 know that's probably not true i mean
it may be true so i'm a very accidental
roboticist um
i
was ready to do a phd in
fluid mechanics at cornell or in
applied mathematics at caltech
when um
the director then of the robotics
institute at carnegie mellon just sort
of showed up
at my alma mater
and he actually came home
uh for dinner my father was the dean
there and he said you should do robotics
and i said what's that
i guess i i like from movies i have seen
these movies since i applied
and to my shock i got in and then there
was a decision that i had to make
between like uh going to
do fluid mechanics at cornell and uh
and going to do a phd in robotics and i
remember my father who's a you know
distinguished professor
you know the real professor srinivasa
telling me you know sitting me down and
telling me
you know son what the future is
it's turbines it's not robots it's
turbines and to this day i i make fun of
him for saying that but i think i've
been very accidental in terms of what uh
what i've done as a roboticist but
coming back to a point of like what um
what skills are are critical
uh i think i i was very lucky in in just
sort of fortunately accumulating some of
the skills that were useful
um i started programming at a very young
age we got an ibm pc
xt
you know the one with the 500
floppy drives at home
and i i was playing video games on it
and then i decided to write my own video
games
uh and that taught me a lot about just
computational geometry like perspective
mathematics algorithms and things like
that and
i think that was really important that i
could i could write code like a speak
language
um i think the other one was i've always
enjoyed tinkering um i'm comfortable
sort of rolling stuff or building stuff
or breaking stuff mostly breaking stuff
and not being able to put them back
together i think a combination of just
like being able to tinker and having a
sort of an algorithmic mindset and being
being comfortable with computers
uh has been has been successful i'm
actually going to flip this to you but
like
what about you
what got you into robotics
you know that's really interesting
because i started amazon in january as
you know being the person who hired me
here um and you know before then i spent
20 years in the aerospace industry and
i've always just been very passionate
about
working on things that really matter
and particularly like i'm hugely
passionate about autonomy and you know
automation and just kind of generally
making things function without a human
immediately directing it in a way that's
very helpful
uh
to humans and and so
um for me like i've worked across the
product life cycle for a variety of
products you know primarily space-based
satellite based uh from a spacecraft
autonomy perspective and i've had the
opportunity to work on and deploy work a
lot of missions do a lot of really great
things and um
i i'm super excited to have the
opportunity to innovate faster here at
amazon and for me robotics is an
extension it's it's under the umbrella
of autonomy like just kind of that
general fundamental um kind of pressing
forward with respect to uh enabling
things to function without a human
immediately having to direct it to in a
way that's hugely helpful and and works
alongside humans and then of course
robots are just super cool like i'm a
huge fan of isaac asimov in the robot
series and so um i've always been a big
believer in just kind of following my
heart and you know right now my heart is
here
awesome yeah with respect to like
science fiction and movies like same
here but i'm the one who points out to
my kids like that's not that robot's not
possible this is not
are actually really inspiring and uh
and excited and i think that's that's
something for me that uh i think i've
been incredibly fortunate
um
to
be working and be paid to work on
something that i just absolutely love
doing like i love robots
it's just and then for the past 21 years
i have woken up every morning
like loving robots as much if not more
and you know it's it's hard
uh it's hard to explain why it's hard we
tend to anthropomorphize and say i can
pick up a copy mug surely a robot can
pick up a copy mug
but i think
it also helps us
understand something about ourselves
like why do we do
what we do and how we do it and i think
it's
it's been uh it's been super useful and
particularly also for me like having
kids and watching them grow and watching
them
become better at manipulating and
locomoting than my robots
have ever been i think it's certainly
been interesting to watch that journey
even unfolding
at a very personal scale
yeah so sid i have to follow up i have
to ask you even though i'm pretty sure i
already know the answer based on prior
discussion um what is your favorite
video game and do you still play video
games since you mentioned that as kind
of a means for getting into coding
oh i have to have to give the i think
it's like a cool like my favorite video
game is something like incredibly
like thoughtful like missed i used to
play mist i actually did used to play
this but um
i i i grew up i was in grad school when
i started playing video games like uh
more seriously and i would say i spent a
pretty decent percent of my percentage
of my phd uh playing video games uh not
not doing my phd
um and and with a cohort of people who
are all
uh incredibly successful now so there's
something worse i i played a lot of
counter strike growing up um
and uh you know it's a first-person game
and uh and i really enjoyed it
um but um i think
that that one of the nice things about
that video game is that it also
like in general helps you with hand-eye
coordination like i really love playing
sports um i play tennis now i used to
play squash i i run a lot and uh and my
excuse for playing video games was that
it helped me in my hand-eye coordination
uh but uh i don't know it's rather
tenuous
um what about you did you play video
games growing up
so actually so
a story that you know is near and dear
to my heart is that when i was a kid my
brother loved video games and so my
parents would give us like 30 minutes of
video game time each over the summer and
we would stack our video game time to be
able to try and like beat like something
like mega man or something like that and
i was horrible i was so bad at those
games and so i would go first then my
sister would go then my brother would go
like kind of the ringer like the anchor
you know and and um but the one game
that to this day i still love and still
play is tetris and so like that was that
was my game
and occasionally i'll drop into you know
other just kind of like social games
because someone in my family is playing
just as a means for connection but
tetris is the only game that i've ever
really loved to play
yeah
that's great yeah i played a lot of
catches too and my uh ibm pc
had a turbo button
um
and you press the turbo button and
things would go like 10 times faster and
that used to be my my favorite joke when
my friends would be playing tetris and
they would be beating me i would just
sort of sneakily press the turbo button
and make all the blocks fall
but uh yeah there's somehow
you know this sort of combinatorial
optimization uh a mathematically hard
problem somehow seems to be
uh rather easy and effortless for humans
uh which is which is again kind of kind
of interesting
yeah
okay great so let's see so sid
so we've talked about how you got into
robotics can you talk a bit about how
your career has evolved over time
um i think i i owe a lot of my
[Music]
robotics
like the way i think about robots do
a couple of things right like one is um
i started working on robots in 1999 this
is a very long time ago almost half my
life
uh and
uh and i think i
i i started at the robotics institute at
carnegie mellon and
it was we didn't know it back then but
it was really the birth of a lot of
really exciting and interesting things
happening
working on self-driving cars with the
grand challenge and urban challenge
you know i put humanoids for the
robotics challenge a whole bunch of
other things
and i sort of
really enjoyed the that time because it
forced us to be
inventors it forced us to be
entrepreneurs it forced us to i mean
there's something incredibly terrifying
about
being a young grad student and having to
go participate in a big competition
you know where billions of dollars were
at stake and it really
clarified our mind on working backwards
and thinking very carefully about all
the technical choices that needed to be
made to build a product of course we
were not building products for money
back then but but i think it helped us
have a very strong sort of systems
thinking and i think that systems
thinking of
understanding not just how a single
piece works but how all of these pieces
fit together and really
anticipating what the issues might be
when you fit these pieces together
as something that i've learned over time
and actually what i have
are the scars of having done it wrong
and whenever i see a new problem i sort
of point to those scars and say hey we
should probably not do that because i
did it and this this horrible thing
happened
and
i think i've always been very passionate
about
um
you know there's this
we made these promises in robotics you
know this is this is where the hype is
it's really high and we've only
delivered
a fraction of those promises right uh we
can debate what that fraction is but
it's certainly like less than less than
one
uh and so
i feel very responsible for that gap and
i've always very much felt like
i need to do whatever it takes to build
something that has sort of real deep
impact
um i've always also been a very
reluctant academic like i've been a
professor for a while i love i love
being a professor because i love
teaching but i also really
strive for impact and wanting to to make
sure that it's it's impactful i think
along the way i i you know i i was part
of a
uh an early stage company called
berkshire gray that is now sort of
publicly traded
and that journey was also amazing you
know we started off with four people
um
and and now i don't know how many people
my company has uh but i think that
journey of being able to
do it all right like i love writing code
i love building robots i love welding
metal i love i think proving theorems uh
but the opportunity to do it all and to
really um align against metrics and do
it in a way such that you're able to
bring meaningful change has always been
really exciting for me
yeah congratulations by the way on
berkshire gray
thank you it feels uh completely
um alien and odd but uh my dad keeps uh
calling me every once in a while and
complaining about why the stock price is
so low so i'm uh i am i know why he
doesn't get his amazon packages on time
so really i'm doing all of this for my
kids my wife and my dad i guess
who are persistently disappointed with
me
i i definitely get the calls since i
started working here about the packages
and and
and why they don't why they come when
they come i'll just say um
so
okay so let's talk about robotics ai at
amazon so what specifically does
robotics ai do
yeah so
um i own autonomous manipulation and
autonomous mobility in amazon's
buildings
um you know our goal is to
improve our associate's experience
by developing technology and robots
that work with and around people
you know by eliminating human tasks that
involve repetitive lifting
stacking turning
we can really
i think elevate our employees
to engage in higher level tasks that
provide common sense and understanding
and an actual influence that robots are
not very good at
um and and this was a
you know i must say uh just like i spent
several months talking to you about why
you should come and think about joining
amazon likewise it was a big decision
for me um you know i just
um
finished up with bertragrey and i was um
just being a professor just happy being
a professor
and i i did get a call from you know a
bunch of places about about joining and
being part of their efforts and
i asked them all sort of one question
why robots why do you need robots
all i know how to do is build robots
and that's all i want to do so why do
you need robots and i think i found the
answers from several of the others
very tenuous right which is we want to
solve ai whatever that means like dot
dot robots
um and i think amazon was to me
uh one of the few places where uh
there's just a very meaningful
connection between robots
and
um
and and what the business value for the
company was and how we could really
improve our associate's experience
and i think you know we also
one thing i also really believe in is
that
smart people will come up with answers
to questions
but it's really the questions that
matter
and it's our one of the nice things
about being at amazon is that i get to
understand what the questions are right
and i get to frame the correct questions
that you know i can then sort of unleash
upon
amazing brilliant people like you to
answer but i think that
what's really rewarding about
engaging with the industry starting your
own company is that you get to know the
real questions are like that are
meaningful that are tangible and then
you can take them away like those those
questions stay with you forever no
matter what you do and no matter where
you go
yeah
yeah and i just want to echo a couple of
things that you said like one thing that
you said previously you know just with
respect to like really learning from you
know the times that you make mistakes or
you know the times when things don't go
quite right like those are some of the
greatest lessons that inform how you do
things you know in the future um and
then also just the opportunity to help
people to like really
obsess over our customers meet our
customers needs and solve some very real
challenges um
like that that actually need to be
solved uh in order to continue to meet
our customers needs uh and just kind of
like finding the way to truly help
people here is something that is a huge
attractor to me and that i'm excited for
the opportunity uh that being an rai
presents to do that
um
awesome yeah and i think that the you
know one thing i'd also say that like
customer obsession is certainly my my
favorite leadership principle at amazon
um you know when i joined amazon i heard
about all these leadership principles
and
initially i was like oh sure it's like
you know more words
but i think being at amazon i has
reinforced how important it is
they help provide a common scaffolding
for the language that we all know
internally that we should use
uh but also i think um actions matter
louder than
words right i think amazon is one of
those places where we are truly obsessed
about our customers we want to improve
their experience it's a very simple goal
but i think it's a goal that underneath
it has like so much complexity in it
yeah
yeah no agreed and i think customer
obsession is probably my favorite
leadership principle as well that or
think big uh
yeah
okay so okay so
if there was one current hurdle
in robotics you know ideally but answer
however you choose uh that could get
completely solved today
what would you choose
oh my uh
so many hurdles
my life is filled with hurdles um
let me let me think a little bit broader
about it i i think uh and and then i'm
gonna
whenever i see these guys i'm gonna put
it back to you so you can keep it
processing in the back of your head um
i i think um
i i do strongly believe that we should
have
much greater
access to robots and ai
i think that um you know i feel very
fortunate that i
you know studied at the best place in
the world to to do robotics i
worked at some of the top schools the
top companies
um
and
and but i i do feel very
um
very fortunate to have done that and and
i and i and on and when i was young i
was a little sick i never got to see a
robot
uh because that just there's no
potential there's no scope for doing
that so i think when the when the next
little little mia grows up i do want
them to have a far greater access to
robotics and ai
and tools that can empower them to
really
like
do whatever they want to do with with
this technology i do believe that
um
you know we are mere
sort of
uh placeholders or
the the great things that our future
generations will do
uh to make sure we don't screw things up
but i think we also it's our duty to
make sure that the future generation has
all the access that they need such that
they can
really understand what the nitty-gritty
of robotics is i think really
um the biggest hurdle right now is
democratization of robotics and making
sure that the technology as well as the
the opportunities are available to
everyone around the world so that
everybody has an equal opportunity to
innovate
what about you
okay so um so yeah i as i resonate 100
with everything that you said and you
know i know this is something that we're
both passionate about like i'm hugely
passionate about lowering the barrier of
entry for understanding topics like
artificial intelligence and robotics and
you know i genuinely believe that uh
through lowering the barrier of entry
like it allows to increase inclusion and
diversity of thought and truly be able
to
allow us to solve some of the most
challenging problems like technically um
optimally end you know most efficiently
and you know that leads me directly to
like what for me is the biggest barrier
is um just helping people to understand
uh human awareness kind of surrounding
the realities of artificial intelligence
we've got all these great science
fiction movies and you know books and uh
and you know the most common question
that i get asked when people find that i
work in ai like over decades uh has been
are you gonna build skynet you know it's
like is terminator going to be a thing
you know and kind of questions like that
and so like truly increasing awareness
surrounding the reality of what
artificial intelligence is uh for the
general population like understanding
that you know what's happening now is
analogous to what happened during the
industrial u
um and that you know people are
genuinely happier you know some of the
technology on the other side of the
industrial revolution than before and
and just trying to find a way to to make
sure that we move forward in a way so
that people have awareness have the
education like we're being inclusive so
that what we're building like is truly
able to to better our society and just
generally help people
yeah completely agree and i think also
that narrative needs to go
um beyond us to
to our leaders right like i don't think
i think robotics is hard i think we all
need to accept and acknowledge that it's
hard and we need to really open
open the back you know lower the
barriers and open the doors so that
everybody can access them and i i
definitely hear you there
okay
so
so how have you been able to transition
uh so you're a very very strong science
leader so how have you been able to
transition from a science leader to
being an effective product leader
yeah that's been quite a journey i must
say and it's uh i must be uh you know
i'll also say that
uh it continues to be a journey i think
i i continue to evolve as a scientist
uh and i continue to evolve as someone
who's building products uh and i think i
continue to evolve as a leader and a
manager and uh you know of an
organization
um and i think you know like any
by growing any muscle
um it requires a lot of work and it's
painful
you know it does it does hurt um and and
also we have to accept that um
you know when some muscles grow others
will will naturally atrophy and we're
going to just be accepting of that i
think a few things one is um
i do very passionately care about
building products i'm very much a a
nails person rather than a hammer person
like
i i like to work backwards from a nail
over a solution
and i am very very obsessed with doing
whatever it takes to solve the problem
and honestly if you can do it without
robots
that is great you know there's this uh
i'm sure the other fields have this too
but
there's a funny code which says if you
have a problem
and you add a robot to it now you have
two problems i
totally completely believe that i think
we sometimes tend to complexify when
really what we need to be doing is is
simplifying
um
and i think i um and the other thing i
would say is that like you have to
genuinely believe in wanting to build
products
for the sake of building products and
not for anything else and i think i've
realized more and more
possibly as i've gotten older and you
know
more gray hair that like unless i don't
truly believe in something i just don't
do it i just i just
and i and i wish i could tell my younger
self that like just that
don't don't really believe in the
trappings but just like do what you like
doing i know this sounds all very very
hollow uh coming from a ten-year-old
professor uh who has a job for life uh
but uh i i do i do believe that that's
that's definitely that's definitely true
i i think one other thing is just um
there's a lot that goes into building a
product that is not science i think a
lot of startup founders or a lot of you
know even technologists that i work with
say oh i got this cool
you know cool idea cool tool we should
do it
and it's really about like the what why
where when how like you know um you
could build a flying car and nobody
might want it right honestly like
history is strewn with such examples of
things that nobody wants even though it
is technically really really hard to
create
um so i think i i love working with you
know
the finance teams i love diving deep
into finance i love diving deep into the
product product space i love thinking
about requirements i love thinking about
safety i love thinking about
working with pr hr legal all of those
just to understand
what the and there is a science to it
right there is just this really
wonderful science to thinking about how
all of that happens so i think i i've
enjoyed that i've made
numerous mistakes and continue to make
numerous mistakes both as a scientist
as a manager and as somebody who owns
products that that need to work but i
think um the bottom line is that you
have to really enjoy it and if the shoe
doesn't fit
uh you shouldn't try to stick it in i
think in general
like you will realize at some point that
like you love doing x or love going by
one other thing i would say is that i've
i've always been very single-minded in
what i've done um
and that involves saying no to
a lot more things that i say yes to i do
very few things actually
um and but what i do i try to do as
with as much
single threadedness and dedication as
possible
uh so that it doesn't also come in the
way of my life right like i i love to
cook i love to play sports i love to
hang out with my family i love to have
my weekends for myself
i love to think um and and i think being
able to find time for all the things
that you love
is really really important in addition
to the work that you're doing
yeah
agreed
and um yeah no i i especially just want
to highlight the kind of to simplify it
robotics can be a hammer but not
everything's a nail and you know this is
something that i would say pretty
frequently and kind of like my old
job as well it's like everything like ai
can be a hammer but not everything's a
nail and so like i kind of resonate with
like kind of the right solution for the
right problem uh and and just kind of
especially kind of like in trying to
meet the customer's needs and then push
product so
i i think one other thing that i would
recommend to people if they were
interested in
uh
being a product leader or being a
science leader
is and this is my own personal
suggestion i would recommend this to
everybody is
um
put yourself in a situation where your
failure has material consequences
um you know whether you're a professor
or whether you're a politician otherwise
you're just dabbling
and i i've always rejected dabbling
because i've always wanted to be in
situations where
the work that i did had real
consequences
and
you know whether if it succeeded or if
it failed and that somehow really
sharpens me and gets me excited about
doing it um
and and so i i don't i don't
particularly i know while it's nice to
have some safety nets i do i do also
think that we should
take the leap of faith and do
do something that
whose success or failure has material
consequences
yeah
okay great so so sid where do you
generally get your ideas to develop new
solutions like where do you get those
ideas from
um
that's the great question um you know i
think i love um i love two things one is
um
observing the world
and the other one is like trying to
explain things like i love explaining
things to my kids i love explaining
things and i love teaching um and i
think the
act of teaching and the act of
um
explaining
really forces you to ask the sort of the
five why's like why is this happening
why is this happening again why is that
happening not and on um and i and i do
i'm very curious like i i love
reading about various things and also
um i think robotics is one of those
things where
um
you watch the world behave and you try
to ask okay like why is it behaving like
the way it's behaving and how do i how
do i think about it clearly so in many
ways it is a very descriptive science
in that when i when i look at a robot
picking up a coffee mug
and i write in a you know proven theorem
and write an algorithm and build a robot
that picks up a coffee mug in some ways
i am explaining using the language that
is available to me how a coffee mug is
picked up and so it is it is in a way
uh being able to write down like you
know just like a painting is a way to
like being able to capture and render
reality in some in some other form uh or
coding is about rendering an idea in you
know in the coding language so i i
always i enjoy doing that
um and and i think it's uh it's also i
love listening to people
particularly subject matter experts
um in any subject matter right um i
think
that's why i really enjoyed
talking to our associates at our
performance centers talking to the gm's
talking to the people the boots on the
ground and asking them like oh hey
what's up like how can i help
um and i think like also to draw an
academic analogy
one of the projects that i work on at as
a professor at the university of
washington is
uh on a robot
that can help
feed people with upper extremity
disabilities
um and the reason i started working on
that problem was because i visited the
the rehab institute of chicago it's now
called the ability lab
um and i just asked people like
what can i do
that can make your life like that can at
least like attempt to make your life
better
and the top request from all of them was
that they just wanted to be able to eat
by themselves and not have to be fed by
a caregiver
and so i was like okay i'll do that that
sounds meaningful and important and i'm
sure it's challenging and so why not i
think i think being able to really
interact closely with your customers and
ask them like what do you want
um
i think we often as technologists have
this hubris of like you know you you
will want what i give you uh and that
may be true in many cases obviously the
the horse versus car analogy and all
this the the universe is replete with
analogies of people not being able to
articulate what they want but i think
that is really disrespecting the
customer just because it's true once
doesn't mean it's true all the time
and history has shown that like you know
we've invented so many things that are
that we think are useful but are not um
so i think talking to our customers has
been has been really really really
valuable i'm going to throw that back at
you that's a good question for you
because
you do brilliant things how do you do
that
where is your inspiration
oh gosh um so i uh so i said think big
was my favorite leadership principle and
so i kind of i think of myself as
someone who doesn't just think of
outside the box but i exist outside of
the box and so like i i do a lot of um
like i i'm kind of very uh thoughtful
and i try to be very observant and i try
to listen a lot and i try to draw
analogies between experiences i try to
leverage some of my experiences that
might be unique from my perspective
i like particularly coming from
aerospace you know in defense and now
being in robotics just kind of
leveraging um like my past experience
and bringing kind of that new like
diversity of thought in many ways you
know to robotics now i am
i i also like i like i'm just super
passionate about like kind of like the
fundamentals just kind of like first
principles and just kind of like
breaking things down um to fundamental
problems to solve and and so like for
example like when i when i first started
out i didn't know anything about
controls theory um but i did know about
intelligent agents and just kind of like
the importance in ai of being able to
perceive your environment the ability to
act on your environment the ability to
um to make decisions to have some kind
of you know reasoning engine and you
know when i first started learning about
controls on the job like it was
completely analogous to me uh to you
know how for controllers like you have
to define your environment you have to
you know create some kind of
mathematical model for your environment
um and you have to be able to perceive
you have to have sensors you have to
have actuators you have to you know have
some kind of like reasoning engine in
some sense and so like
a lot of my ideas come from drawing
analogies based on my experience so
seeing something new that i might not
have depth in or be expert in and kind
of relating it to something that i do
have depth in and just kind of looking
at it uh through a different lens and i
feel like that's that's been effective
for me you know in you know at least a
couple of instances like in my career
and uh but yeah like generally for me
it's like like there is no box you know
like there's no box that's controls
that's ai that's robotics you know like
there's just a whole bunch of
experiences and you know
and you can just kind of apply kind of
these different fundamental principles
to anything really and just kind of
figuring out different perspectives of
how to do that
makes sense cool
cool so um so okay so now so one that i
think is super critical that we cover
is what advice do you have for people
interested in starting career in ai and
robotics today so you've given some
anecdotes that i think are hugely
helpful and that were even like very
useful for me to hear but just you know
generally like what advice do you have
to give for folks who might be listening
today
um first of all i'd say you should do it
stop what you're doing and work out
robots
but um i think one thing i would say is
um
robotics is still at its infancy
um
and
uh this is both a blessing and a curse
more of a blessing
you know unlike other fields that
require
uh you know
tens of years of work to like perfect
how to use an instrument or perfect how
to develop techniques or even learn the
language by which you can describe
problems and solutions
um you know the textbooks for robotics
have yet to be written there are a few
um we'll all write some but those
haven't yet been written and and so i
think
the barrier to entry for robotics is is
really low particularly if you are in
sort of adjacent fields right like for
example case in point u right
um because really it is like you said a
um a combination uh you know a beautiful
dance of so many different components
that need to come together
um and so many different disciplines and
so i think my
recommendation
like
again i'll go back to the point i made
about like do something that like puts
you in a state where your work is
relevant you know if you're an undergrad
or a grad student i would i would
recommend that you go
find an internship
um in a place where robotics is actually
the core business
uh not robotics is something cool and
fancy to have but like robotics is
actually material for the core business
and i go through that experience like
live that experience be put through the
fire of actually having to deliver
something that matters
and i think a lot of people who talk a
lot about robotics um
often
haven't experienced the fire of like
production and delivery
and and i think there's there's a lot of
clarity that comes with that um i think
for people who are working on sort of
recreational robotics like if you're a
hobbyist um
this is a an incredibly wonderful
opportunity to work on robots because
just of the huge uh cambrian explosion
of robotics tools that are available for
example
like aws has a whole bunch of tools for
example like deep racer or even
sagemaker tools for being able to
explore uh ai and robotics uh or even
you know my own udab lab we have these
little mushroom cars one called size
race cars uh we use for teaching and
education so i think
um really
um being able to be very grounded and
dive deep into solving something is
important because one thing that we
often get misled by
is we look at
um
youtube videos of robots uh and you
think ah it's all salt like everything's
soft like surely this thing can like do
a backflip so why can't we do anything
else and i think the the challenge is
that it's not the one time does it that
it does the back flip but 50 million
times that it doesn't then it needs to
do and that's why i that's what i find
the most fascinating is is
you know every time we if you watch high
speed video of people picking up a
coffee mug you're just humbling all the
time right we're just touching we're
failing we're making single contact and
we're taking off the contact and so it
is really about closing the loop and
like figuring out what to do when things
go wrong that is the most critical
aspect of robotics like when things go
right
the youtube video
you know it's easy to do but taking
something from like 80 to 96 where
you're systematically and methodically
addressing all the things that go wrong
like that's that's the most important
learning for somebody to get um and i
think that's where
uh you know the
the people the the real roboticists like
get their most joy in taking something
from 80 to you know 95 96
and i think you should really embrace
the
uh you know embrace the suck and embrace
the process and really commit to doing
that
yeah
excellent thanks sid so
final question and i'm going to just
mention briefly before we jump into the
final question i'll mention again after
that we do have another panel coming up
after this and so please do stay on uh
there's a panel that's going to be with
it's going to be featuring amazon
recruiters and they're going to be
discussing career opportunities so if
you're interested in working in robotics
they're going to be talking about amazon
teams that work in robotics and career
opportunities with those teams so please
do stay on after the question
so
okay so final question
amazon just added a new leadership
principle uh and it's surrounding being
earth's best employer and i'm just going
to go ahead and read it because it is
relatively new and it's really important
that you know we kind of stated as is so
the leadership principle reads leaders
work every day to create a safer more
productive higher performing more
diverse and more just work environment
they lead with empathy have fun at work
and make it easy for others to have fun
leaders ask themselves are my fellow
employees growing are they empowered are
they ready for what's next leaders have
a vision for and commitment to their
employees personal successes whether
that be at amazon or elsewhere so i'm
hugely interested in
your thoughts like can you elaborate on
what this leadership principle means to
you
uh so first of all thank you so much for
reading out the leadership principle you
know
we're a writing culture and we take a
lot of pride in making sure that we
articulate clearly all the words so i
think i think thank you thank you for
doing that
um
and and this is my personal take on it
and i'd love to hear your thoughts on it
too
uh i think as leaders we really
owe it to our employees to strive to be
your best employer
um and and i think one of the things
i've realized um you know being a leader
and having a team that's now spread
across you know all over the world
uh
has been that like we all
look at the world through
uh really sort of very very different
lenses and these lenses are
shaped
sharpened scarred
uh by our own life experiences
um and
and i think it's very important to
understand and acknowledge that
and
to evolve our own lenses to appreciate
that i think that's that's been the
biggest and honestly that's been a big a
growth opportunity for me
um
to accept and acknowledge that the world
is different through everybody's you
know we're all looking at the same
elephant but we see it in in different
ways and it's important that we do see
it in different ways we have a great
diversity of views
and it's important that all those views
are included in the conversations that
we're having around what we need to do
and that's that's not easy because you
know sharing a common vocabulary all
that is really really important
um i think one personal experience for
me is that like i
absolutely
love robots
and i would work on robots like you know
i just i just enjoy so much the the
the challenges that come with working
with robots and it's taken me
uh honestly a while to understand and
appreciate that
um sometimes people
who
i work with very closely may love things
other than robots
and you know it took me a while to
understand i'm like what you don't love
robots like come on it's robots
robots
but i think that's super important
um
i think
you know very very adjacent to that is
the and i do strongly believe in
uh you know strong opinions
that are held loosely and it's important
to
to understand and evolve them
um and and this is all uh i think
a large part of it is
acknowledging that this is a
a principle that we need to
focus on
um and
having mechanisms not just good
intentions but building mechanisms such
that we can actually enact these um
effectively
i'll throw it over to you
okay so
so yeah so now that was really great
that's hard to follow i think for me
this leadership principle truly means
just leading with empathy you know which
is something i'm very passionate about
leading with empathy and just
acknowledging that different people have
different experiences and um and just
trying to put yourself in someone else's
shoes to be able to at least acknowledge
if not really understand those
experiences and you know and and truly
just moving forward in a way such that
you know we can kind of look at the
available population you know that
represents our customer space and and
just kind of note that like looking at
the kind of breakdown of the available
population you know versus you know the
population that we have you know
building robotics uh building robots
working in ai and and just kind of note
the discrepancy and you know try to find
the path uh to to help to enable um kind
of you know greater greater diversity
greater equity in a greater inclusion
you know in
in the fields in these highly technical
fields uh in order to make us better uh
as a whole as a company as a society you
know as the world and so
uh
that's what this leadership principle uh
means to me and you know i'm super you
know excited for the future
thank you
so sid is there anything that you want
to add before we wrap this up
um
no i'm i'm all set thank you so much for
this conversation i really enjoyed it um
i know as you said there's a short panel
that is that is going to be there with
our recruiters after this so i'm really
looking forward to that
um but uh yeah it's been it's been a
blast and we should do more of these it
would be so much fun
this is fun
and thanks so much sid and yes just uh
keep emphasizing it please stay on there
is going to be a short panel like with
the recruiters who can give you really
good specific information about uh about
opportunities uh to work on amazon teams
and robotics so thank you thank you sid
for the conversation this was great
thank you